ladies first forum were delighted to
have you with us and we are extremely
honored by our guests today and our
speaker today that he has come here
during the busy schedule of the United
Nations General Assembly
I'm Jeff Sachs I'm director of the Earth
Institute at Columbia University and
very proud to have a team of sustainable
development experts they keep Volusia
the big challenges that you're going to
hear about our guests today of course is
a president Alpha Conde the newly
elected first Democratic leader of
Guinea this is a
we have with us an individual who has
fought for more than half a century for
democracy in his country first the
struggle for independence from colonial
rule and then a decade's long and heroic
struggle for democracy in Guinea and as
you know that long struggle proved to be
victorious finally last year in guineas
the first democratic multi-party
election which president Conde won in
November 2010 and thereby capping more
than 50 years of effort for that goal
the country that the president has now
is now able to lead is of course a
country with profound challenges 50
years of misrule and mismanagement and
authoritarianism and lots of military
upheaval has left Guinea one of the
poorest countries in the world as I'm
sure you know and as I'm sure we'll hear
about a country of ten million people
with vast resources but vast poverty is
the reality that president Conde
confronted as he came to office so we're
going to hear an extremely exciting
story by a great fighter for democracy
and a person of enormous vision we're
also delighted to have with us today
ambassador mama de Torre who is the
permanent representative of the Republic
of Guinea to the United Nations and I
understand also we have the seniors from
the Brooklyn International high school
are they here raise your hands all right
so half of the seniors are from Guinea
mr. president and studying in
Brooklyn International high school thank
you for being here we're really happy
that you're here
so without further ado let me express my
tremendous satisfaction and great joy
that the president Conde is here as
guineas first Democratic president and
that he is honoring us today with the
introducing the Columbia community and
the broader New York City community to
the challenges of Guinea as Guinea
embarks on its democratic path mr.
president thank you so much for being
here the body double deal to live a
president dat president deal and some
digital account raft as fugitive profess
and she Divini professor
lose interest that's the people I want
to talk to you about
the addicted the dictatorship that we
had were misinforming they had a lot of
misinformation but with the new
technologies and the development of the
network of information the people from
my little village receive the
information at the same time that you
receive them therefore information is
the beginning of the how can I say the
end of the dictatorships we have an
Africa businessman people with education
in Africa that is following the example
of China but in some years Africa will
be more powerful than China and Africa
has the two-thirds of the basic
commodities of the world but we are not
going to insist on that aspect
why are we so backward and I think it
was the civil war
it's very simple the civil war it was to
take their diamonds but the women in
Africa they don't wear the diamonds who
wears the diamonds at the European and
the United States women and then the
other problem was the total absence of
democratic elections when a dictatorship
is organizing the elections it
systematically fraud it real position
doesn't have any other resources
then abide therefore the most important
thing is to eliminate that score scourge
the Civil War permits to the arm dealers
to sell their weapons they sell their
weapons for the rebels they sell the web
the weapons for the those the
government's who want to defeat the
rebels basically there are the
governments that are sustaining that are
supporting the dictatorships and I
remember a speech open all the masseter
of the United States in Guinea we said
that there's no democracy if there's no
democratic development and economic
development we need a unified score what
is important is the democracy the second
argument represented is that Africa
needs stability
therefore we have to avoid changes of
regime
therefore the dictatorship were
sustained supported it's only in 1990
after the collapse of the Berlin Wall
that we started promoting democracy in
other countries and I think it was the
collapse of the Berlin Wall what gave us
the possibility of exceeding into
democracy but we have a lot of
Occidental powers
we want to establish an international
network
mr. DLA yadamma has intervened with the
presence of the president of Senegal
Abdou Diouf the Minister of government
allowed the edema to destroy the
democratic government that has been put
in place at that time however with the
evolution on the in the world everybody
started understanding that Africa cannot
stay on the side of the evolution of
history in the world but a Occidental
countries and a democracy is it vision
of different geographies sometimes they
close the eyes about dictatorship but
there are other states like Mugabe and
others what we reproach to some of the
heads of states is that they are not
giving to the people but they have
extreme need for I listen to mr. Obama
that made a trip to Africa to Agra and
he said that we need a solid institution
he spoke with Ben Ali with Cato but I I
am in politics for 50 years Ben Ali was
the protected person for the Occidental
democracies if you are a head of state
in Africa the economy doesn't have
friends yesterday they were
accepting Denali but I said in Paris
that it is not the springtime the Arab
Spring time it is the African Spectre
the democracy it has is in the hands of
the young people they have nothing to
lose they have everything to win but the
people said mmm are going Guinea why
don't we do what the two Tunisian people
have done the woman would say to the
other have money you don't have courage
look what happened in Tunisia every day
there's more people on the streets we
people have intervened in Libya there
was a humanitarian action we were
against of course is intervention
foreign intervention in Africa is the
African people who is going to solve the
problem of democracy in Egypt it was
different it was a popular movement that
was opposing the dictatorship in Libya
was an are the armed forces in armed
group that was of those in Tunisia it
was the same thing it was the population
in Syria
it's a popular movement but in Libya it
was a Royalist group that were the
Friends of the royal family it
corresponds to the African Union to
solve the problem in Libya but we cannot
compare that with Syria in Syria people
are massacred every day I would like you
to have another image we cannot speak
about democracy as a unique
saying it is not the same thing for
every country of the third world we see
therefore what I am interested in is not
to talk about my my life it's to speak
about Africa today's Africa and
tomorrow's Africa if you are interested
what is going to happen to the young
people in Africa if it is going to be
conveyed those people are going to be
condemned to live in misery or the whole
of Africa is going to shed the change I
was surprised
of the extraordinary capacity of China
today it's a wonderful Society but what
do they have more than not and so we
have they have the rigor they have the
sense of work
are we not capable of rigor the Chinese
are working 24 hours every 24 hours but
I say to the genious if you want to
advance you have to do the same I have
imposed also that certain areas should
work 24 hours per day but we have less
circulation of money we cannot pay
salaries of 24 of 24 hour 7 but we are
looking at the American youth of the
African youth we have more young people
than China we are something now we are
starting now we're at the moment where
the regime is very advanced before we
have computers of a pig as a room now
it's totally different look at the
telephone you so have cables and stuff
today we have a tiny little thing
therefore there is an acceleration of
history which means that our development
is going to be accelerated too
but we have a very serious thing to
consider to the Germans
give us give us a little more time you
are an economy that is based on
production is not a financial but it's
not the industrials who are making money
now is the financial people but we are
the pre-industrial country what do you
do with a pre-industrial economy you
have to change the culture you have to
get out of our agriculture but the war
against the British what was it it was
the war of resources France wanted to
build production it was protectionist I
was in Paris there was a financing of
the economy
they have presented civil servants that
were in charge but we are never talking
about firing civil servants in France
but we put we if if we fire a certain of
the of the civil workers and I in my
country there's going to be a much
better situation we know we know what
are the problems of the economy what is
happening when they are not yelling it
exactly what is happening in the
structure we are talking about budgets
they are talking about money it's the
problem that is a systemic problem is a
problem of the system it's very
difficult to finance the new investments
the development the development of
investment will give us an excess budget
this is how we must see Africa it's not
the problem of work Africa needs to have
its own political vision we must have
men of courage who say no this is the
route and what we're supposed to follow
unless we have this independence and as
long as we are following what is
dictated to us we will not succeed
that's what I wanted to tell you I don't
want to talk to you about Guinea I want
us to discuss about Africa and the
future of Africa for me it's very
optimistic I know that it's not going
well I'm talking about West Africa and
Cape Verde elections democratic
elections in Ghana in Cape Verde in
Benin in Niger in Bamako in Guinea in
Liberia and Sierra Leone in Guinea
Bissau
years ago these were the terror ships
how many military regimes are still
there of course we have still problems
in Africa and Africa is going through a
lot of progress I want to speak to you
about a new Africa that you don't know
you don't know it because you don't hear
about it it's not the Africa of
multinational corporation but Africa in
movement that wants to change and that
wants to change through the next
generations this is what I want to tell
you and I wanted to discuss with you
thank you very much
first of all let me thank president Alfa
conduct I would like to add my voice and
the voice of the Institute of African
Studies welcoming the President of
Guinea but also on welcoming you at this
world Leaders Forum event
my name is mama did you find professor
of African to be Middle East South Asia
and African Studies and the Department
of History I also direct the Institute
of African Studies what I would like to
do very quickly after this very
important keynote address by the
President of Guinea inviting us to jump
into the discussion this future the
present and the future of Africa I would
like to take this precisely opportunity
given to us to engage directly with him
so you I think all the students they
know the rule of a game you have to step
over to one of a mic ask your question
be very brief and precise in order to
have really a deep discussion so thank
you very much for coming so I will begin
in this side and give you what my go
ahead
studies mr. president
actually Asian countries dictatorship
you face many challenges and I'm just
very curious what kept you going what
motivated you would what got you to
motivate other people to strive for
democracy what kept you living each of
those days we were imprisoned and facing
that struck
well Japan I think you know all people
are for democracy and the African
peoples like the Guinean people very
nationalistic country population you're
young you don't know the history in 1958
Guinea was the only French colony that
voted no voted for independence at that
time there was a will in Guinea to
liberate itself to free itself however
freedom did not bring about its fruits
at that point there is ignorance
everybody wants independence but
ignorance is what stands in the end away
the advantage that we have today is the
development of telecommunications radio
television I'll take you for example you
can compare America to Africa to China
and to Europe so you have a means of
comparison you have a way to compare
Africans want to live like other
countries they have good schools and to
have good education now they are ready
they are more ready they are not ready
to accept misery and non independence
because they know they can get better
but when you're ignore what they don't
know what's happening you don't know
what you can get when you see that
people in the United States in Europe
can live better you start to have a will
or to want to get better and I would
like just to let you know that you can
ask your question in English or in
French translation is available thank
you for speaking as thank as a fellow
Guinean
I am very proud that you are yet well
the awareness about our country I have a
question before you were elected there
was violence against the Fulani people
and corruption how do you plan to change
that this is Judy yes this is what I
said the press and Internet what is the
situation in gaming I want you to know
what is the reality we led a campaign
for the purification of everything
democracy is not for this one or this
one
the you can be a president it doesn't
matter where you come from
and what is your ethnicity so democracy
is not against all ethnicities it's it's
for all of Mississippi's everybody has
seen it this president or that president
closed stores so if you don't want to
buy products if you don't want to lose
the opportunity to buy products you keep
them in the fridge so we knew closed
stores you caused famine in the
population what happened after the first
round everybody said no the others said
no this is not a question of alpha this
is a question of defending the Republic
they want to impose the point of view on
us so we cannot we should look at
everything not in a lopsided way they
they used to use the politics of fear by
saying if you're not for the president
you're for terrorism this is a politics
of fear I fought for 50 years the hours
condemned to death however we have to
restart which reality there is no
violence against this ethnicity or the
other the felonies or others there is a
balance against everyone everyone who
uses and who wants to say no to the
government I don't have anything against
traders against the businessmen as long
as they pay their taxes I told them that
they told them they told us you have to
come to us I am the president and I will
come to you so I asked to meet with them
to meet with a committee of the wise
amongst them they came from the jungle
of higher Guinea and they came and they
met with the wise men from futa I said
that Guinea is like a vehicle with the
four ways if you take will take down one
wheel take off one wheel it's not gonna
work however we must have a credible
program that uses reason and logic and
subjective arguments that does not pin
Muslims against Christians or Christians
against Muslims or this group against
and I think the youth you the youth
study students of the University you
must have a critical mind a critical way
of thinking do not take for granted for
truth what you receive what they tell
you but look for reality I I fought for
democracy in Guinea against the
secretary and he condemned me to death
my goal is that the people of Guinea do
not suffer what I had to go through you
do you know this if do you know if in
New York do they do they consider you
Fulani or any other ethnicity no they
consider your Guineans this is what I
want people to think about and to feel
in Guinea there are many dead people in
85 and 95 in 2000 and said one dead
person is already too many dead people
is only too much we have to avoid this
violence and establish justice Guinea
has to accept its past 85 it's us 80 70
times 97 2007 it says we were
responsible for all these events and we
have to recognize the crimes which we
will we were responsible I want to give
you more information that in Guinea
there is no
a prosecution against a specific group
on behalf of Columbia University alumni
and current students you would like to
thank very much
to Professor alpha Cornell for his
speech and we are sorry to speak about
this on the last minute but we just want
welcome professor alpha condi in our
University and our suggestion will be to
help the student in order to make
connection with Columbia New York
University the top universities in u.s.
that the only suggestion we have we
don't have question but we would like to
encourage Professor Alpha conduct in
order to make very higher connection
with universities with the u.s. we would
like again to thank him very much for
everything is doing and we encourage him
to do the best we can
he is the president now he is not a
political leader and we are here to help
him in order to implement Guinean policy
and democracy thank you very much and
again welcome to Columbia University
we want to develop education we want
tomorrow if there's a professor who
leads a course in Colombia Guinean from
futa and even from the jungle can follow
the course like you follow a soccer
match this will take a lot of efforts
and energy if we can computerize all
universities and that's what that is my
objective and I said that tomorrow the
Guinean students needs to have access to
the information to the courses when
there is a soccer game you watch the
final game at the same time as that they
watch it in England so my goal is that
tomorrow the Guinean students may have
access to the same information the same
courses as they do in France or the
United States same way as surgeons now
Carriere operations and they follow
these operations in France in Guinea or
anywhere around the world this is what
our goal is but we need to have energy
for this thing we need to have a program
for this a computer program for this and
secondly we need to transfer to know how
you do not have we do not have enough
laboratories enough professors how can
we progress when you don't have all
these means you read the newspapers
every day you read you read economic
newspapers all the time
magazines in two or three years after
that you're behind everybody else I sent
you the question I sent back the
questions how can how can the Guinean
students from our side again is who are
outside so how can they encourage
investors to come to Guinea to invest in
Guinea to invest in their Guinea in
universities because we don't have the
means to it but Bill Gates Bill Gates
can give
means of Dallas to Guinea you must be
the ambassador's of Guinea and you must
talk to the foundations and institutions
that are responsible for such changes to
come and for example establish some kind
of twin city program with Guinean cities
what I can do is encourage you and
facilitate the logistical aspects
however you must take the initiatives
and by encouraging the foundations that
are in the United States therefore I'm
very medicine for example for drugs and
for schools for example you need to
engage them don't be passive as you are
you this is your future not our feasible
so you you do not let yourself be
manipulated by political leaders how can
the Guinean youth know about everything
that's going on around the world this is
your role they need to have access to
knowledge like you you must ask your
question what can we do for the youth of
Guinea
my name is Patrick McMenamin
I'm a student here you have consecrated
a lot of energy since you came into
power in for reforms last week your
minds minister avoided a an important
contract with China or canceled an
important contract which and I would
like to know did you lead an
investigations on the circumstances of
cancellation of this contract with China
and and will this cancellation affect
your relationship with China this is as
far as I know I don't know how we can
cancel a contract if we did not receive
a contract if we did not sign a contract
we we will analyze contracts
case-by-case on a case-by-case basis
the Minister of Mines could not cancel
contract that has not been signed we
have we are democratic country we
respect the law a law professor there is
a continuity for the government it
doesn't matter what kind of over
government you inherit everything that
the other government left you with so we
need to analyze to find the two real
reasons in front of you - legally today
we cannot cancel any contract we can
cancel contract contracts only after
having studied them on a case-by-case
basis and we will follow the due process
and we will define our policies so that
everybody knows that we will not wait
someone or against anyone so this is
what we need to do we need to negotiate
contracts in all transparency everybody
needs to be to know to be aware about
what's going on so for now we cannot
cancel any contract because we do not we
do not even define the framework of a
due process or the general rules so I
don't understand I don't know why and
how come the Minister of Mines can have
the opportunity or the power to cancel a
contract it doesn't have the power the
authority to do that the president is
the one who has the power and the
authority right now so I would ask the
question to the Minister of Mines
because I don't know anything about him
cancel in any contract in Guinea here
there's no channel that speaks French
there's only english-speaking channels
however we have to define the rules the
general rules and the due process but we
are decided determined to make the
change happen we do not want
multinational or international
corporation to exploit the Guinean
people we would we want the Guinean
people to take advantage of their wealth
even though this could be the interest I
put my life in danger where I was
acted and I was elected for change in
again me no matter what the price is I
don't I don't fear anyone anyone but I
respect the law only 15 minutes left
please be brief professor Conde one
knows him Conde my name is Salim
gibberty
my question is about a Guineans who live
outside gave me not just in I says who
want to go back to Guinea to work on one
end these the youth they have a feeling
that they are looking for work that they
could not find however this is a reality
from my point of view when we go back to
Guinea with the diploma with a degree
and we don't have any connection and we
are disadvantaged if you don't know
anyone from the government or don't know
anyone well placed in the government to
get a job if you don't have even if you
have a degree but my question is the
following what real hope do you give
this young young people who want to go
back with a complete project or plan and
reassure them that they can find a job
without having needing anyone to push
them forward really or to help them and
that their qualification is enough to
advance forward the Guineans who are
outside of gimme-gimme-gimme is not what
you believe the people who are also I
think that the Guineans inside against
them I spent two thirds of my life
outside of Guinea
if the Guinean population was against me
I would never have been president today
that situation is completely different
you ask you have two different
situations a young person for example
who comes to gaining what a project has
an opportunity today
I told them that I will do better than
Rwanda you know one will ask you if you
come back to Guinea and wants to start a
project you will have the opportunity
quickly within one week so if you want
to establish or to have a project to
plan a business in in Guinea you don't
have problem but the other problem is if
you make $2,000 in in the United States
you when you go to Guinea you are only
going to make $200 so I asked the
International Development Bank to
finance such projects and I told them
that there's opportunities equal to
those in the United States that can take
place in a Guinea so if you come back to
Guinea today my goal my goal is to bring
most of the Guineans who live outside
the businessman and others in several
Western cities some of them want to come
back some do not want to come back if we
don't have the possibility to offer them
a good salary today I'm telling you you
don't have any obstacle in front of you
if you want to invest in Guinea that
this is our first battle is to fight
against corruption if the president is
corrupted the ministers will be
corrupted but if the president is not
corrupted the ministers can not be
corrupted so I'm telling you there will
be no obstacle now if you want to get a
job you would have to accept the
salaries as they are today not as they
are in the United States but if you want
salaries that are similar to the United
States that will have to wait i if we
want to come back I will intervene in
front of the ministers - even to help
and to guarantee that you have a a
position and a project
okay president I am in charge of the
ministry here he needs a push don't see
a disability really that was once per
capita a two son hello oh yes it's here
well repeat your question yeah it's go
ahead your country now is approaching a
historical macroeconomic inflection
point it's not extraordinary and vast
natural resources and and these could
truly lead to extraordinary and
sustainable growth in GDP per capita did
you please discuss your strategy for
development of the extractive resource
industry and encouragement of foreign
direct investment Messi well musician mm
plow
man we are trying to establish a plan
before I came here I have a very good
news from a big very important economist
in my country he is he has decided to
help us you know I am a professor but I
am very modest
when we need help we recognize it right
now we need technical assistance I don't
have any complexes I don't have any
problem in a knowledge in the cause it's
not at some point we are not capable of
doing by ourselves we have to avoid the
corruption we have to avoid the
manipulations we need an associate we
need somebody who would work with us
when I was in Paris
to ATF dot we have to go back and start
anew and I recognize the communiy the I
recognize that we have a lack of
resources but we are ready to share the
decisions and our riches with our
associates Guinea has to benefit from
the experiences of others but not to
copy the experience it for others we
have to adjust it to the needs of our
country therefore we'll open to
discussion we are open to elaborate a
new vision but our vision could be
improved on and that would help us to
advance of the students many times you
should have played Jeff Sachs in this
into a bush from time to time I don't
know where he used I'm using an African
vocabulary to keep me I'm so happy to
find the Guinean community here and the
interests of students so I wanted to
explain just a couple of things about
what we're doing and what I think
Columbia University can offer in in a
practical way and then encourage those
who are interested to contact me and we
will follow up my email address is Sachs
at Columbia edu s a CH s at Columbia edu
I'm very easy to find and we are very
interested and I discussed with
with the president beforehand expanding
whatever support we can through the
earth Institute which is a an
institution committed to sustainable
development to effective use of natural
resources to sustainability of the
ecology to improving agricultural
potential and to fighting poverty hunger
and disease we have a project called the
Millennium villages which some of you
know which is operating all around
Guinea but not in Guinea right now and I
would like it to come to Guinea because
they think it's an effective way to help
it rural development so our team which
is based in Bamako Mali has been
visiting again Eve recently on several
occasions and we will continue to have
that discussion we also have a Center on
sustainable development at her Columbia
Law School working on the issues of
contracts and transparency in the mining
sector and all of the issues that mr.
president faces in a very tough
challenging way each day and we're very
eager to work with him with revenue
watch with others to help on this set of
issues as well so what I would like to
say for those of you who are interested
in while here at Columbia or in the
greater community being engaged in
Columbia's support of Guinea please do
contact me and I will pass along your
message to the people working in this
project and they will find effective
ways to help you do research assistance
or participate in various aspects of
this work and we're very much looking
forward to being of whatever support we
can right now I think as many of you
have said this is a pivotal moment
with the strong and determined
leadership and we're committed to doing
everything we can from the perspective
of this university Thanks thank you Jeff
we have only in its left I'm not sure
that I will be able to accommodate all
of you as you know is very hard to
change the agenda of a president and
this president hands commitment at 11:20
I'm just telling you at 11:23 he's very
close people will come and move him out
so please be brief thank you very much
Mohammad a demo and since you talked
about transition injustice in Guinea but
there are people who are implicated in
the massacre that happened two years ago
who what in your government also
continue to be there how can we make
that transition move forward when these
people are not brought to justice or
where has the the justice system in
Guinea do so far to address that my my
real question is you talked about Africa
and making transition from what it used
to be in creating Africa of tomorrow but
we looking at where massive land deals
where people are coming from other
places buying this land in for producing
food for export where people in Africa
are hungry and always begging for food
and then we're looking at construction
and infrastructure especially where
roads are built that does not last more
than a decade in some cases and also we
you know thought you talked about Libya
thank you yes my name is Ibrahim I am a
student here at Columbia University and
my collection is very simple and short
since you have taken the Guinean
government can you tell us one one
economic policy you have taken to
address the adverse effects of
extractive companies in Guinea
gabor develop ondraw know and you know
anavar parity we allowed them through a
contract to establish themselves for
exploitation and they have a permit for
export we we want to avoid juridical
scandals we want to avoid dirty
businesses because Guinea has to start a
new part for instance they were the
governor selling to the peasant airlines
very cheaply and those peasants were
selling their land much more expensive
to different companies well now they
cannot do it anymore
we have to take care of that we our
objective is that Guinea should be
economically independent justice is as
important as oil and Guinea now has the
possibility to have a agricultural
riches also so therefore is very clear
that every mining company has to
establish certain school certain
benefits for the people of Guinea
nothing is for free and that should
establish a possibility for authority
take action in certain place
we have to establish the possibility for
our students and to increase the
production to modernize they employ
industrial infrastructure therefore is
very clear that we don't want only a
group of people to profit from the
situation we need transparency everybody
has to work decently and we know and
before they start working with that they
should not exactly what are the
conditions what are the laws they have
to abide by and how they have to behave
I am going to be very fast I passed by
guinea I was there to work with students
and I have to recognize the civil
society was functioning quite well you
suppose I have it and it's I told them
that is it is in their hands it is in
their power to make respect the law and
we discuss we have struggle together and
we're sharing power we are not here to
criticize we have to work all together
that's what I'm trying to instill we are
going to work together and that is the
only path towards progress the that's
the policy that I have want to implement
I created a tripartite Commission to
define the unemployment the retirement
pensions and all that
I am from Burkina Bay I want to know why
all the economic problems that we have
with all the riches that they have why
they have so many economic problem that
we're doing that everything was working
nicely before mankind only can solve the
problems that are clearly established
and defined we have to in order to get
out of that situation we have to define
exactly what the problem is I know that
all the heads of states are trying to do
the same thing in Africa but
we have to establish a strong currency
that is the right of all the people that
if it is currency of West Africa or if
it is going to be in francs but I want
to establish in the African zones in the
West Africa and all that special
currency we have a lot we have a lot of
currency deposited in France so we have
to receipt that back I am a realist and
I'm independent and I say clearly what I
want to say I don't want to be pressured
by anybody so four people are remaining
I'm going to ask you to have a
democratic discussion one second and
pick up two or among yourself I can
accommodate to giving you so I will take
all four thank you very much I was
wondering can you confirm that some of
the generals who were involved in the
2009 massacre are working for your
administration and what is the Ghanaian
justice system doing to bring them to
justice
hi my name is Esther Yaga and I'm
originally from Kenya my question was in
Kenya we've had issues of government
officials getting paid an absurd amount
of money while the country is starving
and we recently underwent constitutional
changes that prevent that and my
question is how do you plan on
addressing that within Guinea or is that
even an issue in Guinea go ahead
Michelle phase II don't
there's nothing in first person
it is an honour for us to see you defend
Africa and the interest of Africa
however we worry about what's happening
in our country we I will talk about the
legislative elections you have named you
have assigned some people who were
favorable to you you replaced the
president of acini who was controversial
before the elections that led to you to
the power and we did not transfer the
competencies and the viewpoints of the
acini you know that in again it's very
difficult to win elections against the
president in power you know that because
for a long time for five years you were
facing the president become a president
I think it's in 1993 you were supposed
to win however he was president in 1993
and you had no way to exert power today
what is what gives the opposition the
possibility to believe that these
elections could be free democratic and
transparent merci Mousavi who Polly de
Janeiro
whose have you you talk about generals
we just came out of the military regime
it's a fragile situation where I tell
people in the West said that we were
going to fight against impunity whoever
wants to go far must have the means Ida
melt Redskin okay when you came before
to Canada you so you saw tanks and you
saw military is military personnel
walking around with military weapons I
retired a number of officers more than
I'm not on for more than four thousand
officers I'm not no Quixote I had I have
to work and see how I can work with the
army I'm a civilian I don't have any
weapons the Guinean military has this a
really bad habit of wanting to really
subdue the people now I'm breaking that
habit but I have to break it slowly if
so I must go slowly take it slowly with
the army I told the opposition's you are
right to act and you are your act to
want free you're right to want freedom
but the people of Guinea right now want
freedom and I have to have the freedom
and the will and I have to have the
means to fight against these people
against the army and I have to give the
means to the people so that they can
fight for themselves in a very effe
efficient way however we must be
realistic if you want to jump ten
hurdles at the same time your own you
will not jump any journal if you want to
jump you have to jump hurdle by her
torso give me time to take on these
hurdles one by one
talking about Kenya there was a civil
war today you have a democratic regime
in in Guinea we started not the fight
against salaries it's not the problem
with salaries it's the problem with
siphoning with the corruption with
stealin money that is not there's people
before had accounts they had public
accounts in different banks and they
right now we closed all the public
accounts and all the accounts are in the
central bank so a person who is working
for the customs for example or for the
government can not just take the money
whenever he wants so it's not a question
of salaries like in Kenya so this is
what I thought well you have a
misinformation we do not say transfer
you know we did not transfer the power
from us any to Mata you have to read
there is an agreement between Maya and
eseni since the elections this is what I
talked about misinformation secondly I
didn't dissolve in Guinea the municipal
councils since two years ago they are no
longer legal however I dissolve the
Municipal Council of cata of arena so
this is what I'm saying you need to be
informed and do not let yourself be
intoxicated what I'm saying when a mayor
can investigates and finds loopholes in
the management they have to take action
this is what was done as a matter of
fact it is against me now I'm using
these laws against them against those
people who were corrupted before I came
to power they used the law to say for
example that whoever led a demonstration
is the one who instigates the
demonstration that was going to pay for
it to be held responsible so I'm using
those laws against them dalla was
Minister for 10 years and I was in jail
for this time this time
and they know what I'm talking about it
I am talking about to them I'm telling
them I'm a democratic I told the ICA
that we need to hold elections however
when they had a non-transparent election
at by the elections they had chaos all
over and they were not following because
there was a there is a bad management so
if we you follow if you follow the
information your intellectuals but if
you do not really have distinguish
between the real information and the
false information you're going to be
like peasants
what is the credibility of a later
somebody who led for 10 years in
corruption and subduing people so try to
think and to reflect forget that your
Maliki of lenio Susu
just use your brain and your logic your
and analyze things you are young but if
you let yourself be intoxicated you're
not going to be doing any favors to
yourself or for Africa i invade you
invite you to Guinea I will pay your
ticket to come and see what is happening
there what I'm saying what I'm saying we
want free and transparent election
elections in in Guinea there is double
or eight times the imposition eight
times the taxes we pay more taxes than
anyone else I said that we have to get
rid of these rules and these laws and we
have to give passports to everybody for
example for free so I am open to
discussion and to critical discussions
and to criticize him so I am but I would
like to ask you do not read
misinformation do not secede do not give
in to misinformation if you want to
really learn about happening in Sydney
but what when we talk about us a me and
myself in the situation that he talked
about this shows that you are
misinformed I am the president and I
don't have any polemic with anyone
ruin my name is at the school of general
studies and talking about our position
there is the talk that the position
leaders we will feel that they have not
been listened to enough by the president
are calling on the people to peacefully
come out at the end of September and
wrote some of the reforms that are
taking place I would just like to
quickly know what is the president's
take on that thank you
Leggett in the movement Guinea is a
democracy and there is a freedom of
demonstration and ilysm is one thing
breaking things is not tolerable and I'm
clear that democracy democracy must
exist within the law anyone who brings
our people to demonstrate and break and
people to those people break the
buildings in everything I'm for freedom
but I'm against chaos they will be held
responsible the opposition opposition
from where they they they they led and
they were working with banner for 10
years where are they those people
governed with him and they participated
in what he did if they had worked and
unders job Guinea would not have been
where it is right now so you must think
those people who did everything would
Conte they are really in bad word
country they responsible for us going on
if they sold their souls for for how can
you sell how can you sell for example
can you sell houses that belong to the
state how can you sell them and take the
money yourself and these people did that
if you want democracy you have to fight
against bad governance and you cannot do
that if you support people who use bad
governance as a way of life actually you
have to really my friends there is no
ethnicity specific ethnicity that who
develop Guinean help to develop Guinea
you must think about Guinea as one
people if you start to think about our
ethnicity and this and that
it nee we will not go forward again he
is innocent and gisni has that advantage
of being able to move forward please let
it move forward opposition can
demonstrate but if there is breaking if
there's a violence if there's looting
that will be held responsible this is
what's happening to Kentucky there's no
chaos we will not break their people's
backs and we will not break cars we will
not cause chaos
the state will apply the law whoever
goes against the lower Peter the rules I
forbid every demonstration because there
was going to be massacres there was
going to be looting I prevented that
from happening in other countries you
couldn't even see when there is an
assassination attempt you couldn't even
see who committed this justice is going
to take care of that in Guinea we know
who's the win everything because
everything is out in the open you will
see we we I did not allow them to arrest
the bowery what I wanted I said that we
if we needed to have an international
arrest warrant for him but he ran out
and he ran away and I said that we have
to let justice take of course if he ran
away from the country that's not a bad
thing but you are young I'm just saying
you are young do not let yourself be
intoxicated need you need to be informed
if I can if I can I can accuse somebody
of killing his father but maybe his
father died a long time ago and he
didn't kill him you have gray matter you
have your brain you are capable of
analyzing and critically and criticize
what's going on but if you take
everything they gave you just swallow it
like cheese without even thinking about
it this is not going to live anywhere
you are students and you would not yet
you're not yet intellectuals as long as
you are not as long as you're not
capable to
analyzed critically what you hear before
you believe it Shan I would like on
behalf of Columbia University the world
leaders forum the Earth Institute and
the Institute of African Studies to
thank President Conde for a powerful
introduction
a very frank engagement with the
question some time very sharp question
of our students also I would like to
thank reliever student the audience for
having made this conversation very rich
and on a personal note I would like to
say two things the first one is related
to president conducts first words when
he said that he will not speak
emotionally and you have seen it
probably he was not emotional because
but he was very passionate and it
reminded me but first time I met him I
was finishing high school in France and
he was still the leader of the
Federation is it redundant Noir and one
thing the second thing which is
interesting at the end of his talk
answering one of the question he
mentioned one philosopher apeun
philosopher and his very interesting
question about you know challenges we
are facing and question we are asking
ourselves he did not mention the name of
a philosopher I will not mention it but
it's part of the thing I shared with him
when I was very young again thank you
very much